oh man yeah all those sword massacres
are when are we gonna get better sores
well you can just walk into any
going-out-of-business store in the mall
and pick up lies hello reject nation
it's Greg Alba yeah I'm John we are
going to watch a fun little video today
learn to fly by the Foo Fighters rocking
thousand official video so one of our
roar tears over at our patreon what
youtubers with patreon never heard of
that in this day and age one of the
reward tiers is whatever video you
requested must definitely do usually
it's a reaction of course and that comes
today from man named Lance door Lance
stores a guy who lives in Canada
hard-working ethnic-looking firefighter
and he is one friendly guy he has a
beautiful family hot-ass wife that I'm
hoping he can eventually have a
threesome with her with another guy so
when they get pregnant with another kid
he is confused on who is the father of
the baby and that they never do a DNA
test so when it comes time to decide
whether or not they should keep this
child that he keeps the kid but the
entire time he's raising that baby boy
or girl he's wondering is this really
mine and it's my fault for agreeing to
the threesome that uncertainty is the
key to a happy family I love you Lance I
wish you the best
[Music]
good thing I never actually saw
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
Wow Hills everywhere already
[Music]
a people don't even like to
yeah mister
[Music]
yeah now I don't understand the tunnel
this video
[Music]
they're also on
whoa
literally singing and playing with the
fubar
that's interactive Gaza right there
[Music]
and others of food fighters in the very
center
[Music]
that was
you
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you know there's someone of that Crowder
just freestylin
[Music]
very well
[Music]
thank you together
we all loved the Foo Fighters seven and
a half minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't good enough that was
terribly guess that this video is gonna
be seen by a huge a huge amount of
people all over the world but to be true
it's being conceived to be addressed
just to five people so Chris Pat Nate
Taylor and Dave Grohl the Foo Fighters
you know it leaves a country where dream
Italy cannot easily come true
but it's a land of passion and
creativity so what we did in here is
just a huge huge miracle I've been
working on this [ __ ] project for more
than one year waking up every morning
thinking about how to make it real and
this is all all that we got
1000 people 1000 rockers that came from
all over the nation at their own expense
low turnout and they just did the ones
don't end up your song so our call is to
ask you the Foo Fighters to come play
for us come and play here give a concert
to all the buzz into Zino so what I'm
asking right they owe you nothing stole
their song
[Applause]
[Music]
and I wish the food by having a reaction
video to this
[Music]
if they saw this they came
for just these thousand people just
added Italy to the tour okay
somehow we skipped Italy all these are
mistake
[Music]
probably less Italy was actually real
[Music]
now one person flashes the camera
oh that we saw let's go back in this
taken
damn
a lot of people someone called it was
like I didn't see my name on here yeah I
scoured through I said I read through
every name I was drummer number 512
you're gonna make a joke John get him
out now to know the math saturation is
important comedy
thousand people
Wow did they go only we had a computer
internet to look up I don't think we
came to speculate that's something we
can find out now
I don't think so too if you years old
yeah they saw this and I guess they went
out there and spent some time with them
and then played a show for them and all
that stuff Wow it was a cell phone video
of Dave girls speaking of very a little
bit of Italian ministry actually part of
italiano so long this is amazing and
we're definitely gonna come out and see
you guys I can't imagine being like a
band to feel this honored by fans of
like did so many people gathered learned
our song just so they can try to get our
attention to get us the play of course
you gotta come out oh yeah it was on
vacation and like everyone started
blowing up his phone like did you see
this and he said like when he finally
watched it he cried he cried yeah what a
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] this guy never cries
that's my motto never suck it up don't
know why do videos ago go back ever yeah
that's a beautiful thing man humbling
yeah I don't want everyone to gather for
rap god that's what I'm gonna do I want
em to play hey 900 DJs with the same
backing track playing and a hundred
emcees the same beat the fast part is
gonna sound like a trainer yeah it's
good it's gonna create this like storm I
think it would be awesome today
I think so this for every every artists
freaking cardi B Britney Spears yeah no
not like bands that's what's the point
of that I'm sorry about people who just
have an electronic beat in the
background there's one singer limited to
that it's way easier to gather piano for
that giant karaoke session show me what
you could some singer song let's do one
of these for like Jason Mraz yeah a
thousand white dudes now be cool
Rebecca Black's Friday just get it all
going dude to be one awesome experience
you can do this with anything in all
seriousness though this is a very
beautiful video I can't imagine what the
honor must be like yeah yeah a thousand
people out of the five hundred thousand
subscribers here could gather together
to do a reaction video in front of a
laptop that would be awesome one laughs
don't worry J I'll share the same line I
really want you guys to come out here
and react to our city to song Hey
thousand people yeah then none so I came
up with late to the party
yeah B oh that would be a blasty blast
yeah I'm going they had to do a good
amount of prep for this I would imagine
though because I mean I'm like I'm
always impressed when I see a band play
with two drummers drumming in unison to
have you know however many this is like
thirty drummers or fifty however many
that's the backbone of a performance
like this believe they were five hundred
accordingly you going to me yep yep
definitely was definitely I don't know I
mean it certainly looked like they had a
lot of drummers I mean they probably had
the most singers I loved that
Giovani easier for everyone to sing
together with video at concerts already
every was already singing with yeah yeah
yeah for freaking drummers yeah yeah I
wonder if like they did it because to me
this read has just come out and play but
this must have been rehearsed yeah I'm
wondering how much they did like if this
was over several days or if they said
like okay send us a tape of you playing
the songs that we know you would
actually play and then come on we'll
figure this out together you know right
I don't know but the fact that they were
able to get any tape where they just
pulled the song off is beautiful I mean
the guy who is putting the whole thing
together look stressed out as hell he's
kind of look like that was great guys
I'm so happy we could do this is we're
like I just want the [ __ ] Foo
Fighters to come here yeah and putting
this together has been a real [ __ ] it's
hard enough to get it like five or so
people to play on time but like a
thousand people all together on time not
even sure if this went well I think I'm
on drugs right now
I've been up for days I was beautiful
hey thanks Lance right I got informed on
this this will be one of those stories I
share with people
sure I'm like the Foo Fighters that much
well you know when the Chili Peppers
gets one you know which I'll be cool it
would be an impressive two because like
not all of their music is that easy to
kind of just you know it's like the
guitar parts and the bass parts and the
vocal they're always very specific you
do something that's not a crazy solo and
everyone's doing a crazy solo together
yeah anyway guys hey you guys can go to
iTunes and listen to the Foo Fighters
cuz we're not them despite what people
always mistake us for and you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell or ring it
whatever dumbasses are saying nowadays
on this YouTube site and I really don't
agree with this thing ring the bell and
check us on patreon where we have
full-length TV show reactions in week
the Q&A is a whole lot of goodies
actually would love to have specifically
you the viewer become a patron eject
today and then just all of our viewers
just you know get apart yeah did you not
hear about the sword massacre